as people entered the game today there
was a unique chance to get
vaccinated the knights teamed up with
immunized nevada today to provide covet
19 shots to
those 12 and older bianca holman has the
story
the energy at the toshiba plaza before
the hockey game was high
people ready to cheer on the golden
knights and protect the valley
a smiths and immunized nevada pop-up
clinic was up and running providing
vaccines
the reason why we're able to do these
things and be at playoffs as fans is
because of vaccines and it's ultimately
protecting ourselves protecting our
community and protecting this country
against the serious threat that is covet
19.
those 12 and older were able to receive
the pfizer shot or the one dose johnson
and johnson vaccine
200 doses all free of charge do it for
yourself number one
stay healthy but if not for you do it
for your family and friends and loved
ones to keep them healthy and not to
pass it on
troy kendrick a season ticket holder
opted for the johnson and johnson
like many people he's been hesitant i've
just been a little apprehensive and
you know weighing the pros and cons and
they convinced me to and i got my mom to
get
my mom's elderly so i want to protect
her and with the free nights had to
sport at the game
it's go nights go i'm excited we're
going to go all the way
bianca coleman 8 news now